did they have you do out like a lie
detector test yes it's called a
polygraph polygraph how effective just
interesting are our previous discussion
how effective are those polygraphs are
really interesting so one of the things
that people don't understand about
polygraphs is that polygraphs aren't
meant to text a lie like they're called
a lie detector yeah but they're not
actually meant to detect a lie they're
built to detect variants from your
physiological Baseline so they're
essentially meant to identify uh
sensitivities to certain types of
questions and then as they identify a
sensitivity to a question it gives the
interviewer an additional piece of
information to direct the next round of
questions so then from there they can
kind of see how sensitive you are to a
certain level of questions and your
sensitivity could be a sign of
dishonesty but it could also be a sign
of vulnerability
so the interrogator themselves the
interviewer themselves they're the one
that have to make B the Judgment call as
to which one it is which is why you
might see multiple in uh interviewers
over the course of multiple polygraphs
but that's really what they're all about
so
I mean outside of they're extremely
uncomfortable like they're mentally
uncomfortable but then there's also
you've got to you sit on a pad because
the pad is supposed to be able to tell
like your body movements but also like
your sphincter uh contractions or
whatever so you're sitting on this pad
you're plugged in you're strapped in
you're tied up and it takes so much time
to get in there and then they start
asking you questions Baseline questions
at first and then other questions from
there and you're just answering the best
you can and you never know what they're
seeing and you don't know what they're
doing and it's really hard not to get
anxious of that anyways and then they
the whole time monitoring the the
readings yeah from like a big they've
got multiple screens and they've got
just it's all information superiority
they have information superiority you're
the idiot looking away from them or
looking sideways of them and trying not
to move because you're afraid that if
you like have gas or if you move a
little bit it's going to vary you from
your Baseline yeah and the whole time
you're worried your heart's racing and
your blood pressure is increasing which
is a variance from Baseline yeah so yeah
that means it's it's an interesting art
or your Baseline correct maybe there's
some people that are just chilling the
whole time and that's their Baseline
right right but that's what they're
doing they're establishing business I
mean I guess that means the polygraph is
uh is this is a skill that you develop
absolutely to do it well so when people
talk about beating a lie detector it's
not that they're telling an effective
lie that's not hard it's not hard to
tell a lie to an interviewer what and
the interview doesn't care if you're
being honest or not honest about a topic
what they're looking for is sensitivity
if they see no sensitivity
that's a big sign for them that's a big
sign that you're probably a pathological
liar if you show sensitivity to many
things then that's a sign that you're
probably an anxious person and they can
still reset their Baseline because they
can tell how your anxiety is increasing
you know in 15-minute increments it's
it's a unique skill I mean a really good
calligrapher is a is immensely valuable
but the uh yeah it's the misnomers the
misconceptions about polygraphs are vast